I'm two and a half picking up some dust, great shadow, four forward, drifting to the right, a little 32nd forward contact light. okay, engine stop, we copy it down, Eagle.
I was eight years old and we were allowed to stay up really, really late one night.
We all gathered around our little black and white TV set and we watched these kind of shifting shadowy images and we listened to Walter Cronkite.
So there's a foot on the moon, stepping down on the moon.
If he is testing that first step, he must be stepping down on the moon. at this point
I wasn't thinking about the other 500 million people that were watching with us.
I had some idea that this was something big, but I didn't know that. what I was seeing was history just kind of unfolding right in front of my eyes.
We were watching images from of all places- the surface of the moon.
It's hard to comprehend that all of human history was going to forever pivot on that moment.
Now it seemed like an eternity for an eight year old.
We watched all kinds of things and we listened, but then that moment came
And the first man in human history stepped onto the surface of the moon and we heard these historic words spoken for the first time,
Of course. you all know, this past week Neil Armstrong, Eagle Scout astronaut, engineer and teacher, passed away at age 82.
He's always going to be the first man that walked on the moon, but his legacy doesn't stop there.
Armstrong understood, it seems.
It was not just him, but the hundreds of thousands of people who made that Apollo 11 mission possible, who owned the achievement.
He never put himself forward, never took advantage of his fame, and he just seemed to move on.
He acknowledged his place in history, but he never made a big deal out of it.
Everything in his life led up to that moment:
His youth and scouting and achievement of the Eagle Scout badge and his education, his selection as an astronaut
and then his selection as part of that Apollo 11 team.
But he had a job to do and, as you listen to him, in his first steps he was an engineer
And he just kind of matter factly recorded what he saw.
There's been no difficulty in moving around, as we suspected.
It seems perhaps easier than the simulation of the 16G that we performed and their simulation on the ground.
And I think that's the real heroism of this Eagle Scout:
He stepped forward, he did his work and in one respect. he led the entire human race
But, more importantly, he served us all by simply doing his part,
And that's the example we can take forward. in our work as volunteers,
We may have lots of accomplishments and shining moments, but in the end we're servants,
We're standing on the shoulders of those who came before. in our mission, just like that of Neil Armstrong's mission, is clear:
To serve selflessly and to work for the interests of our scouts rather than ourselves.
And now for you, Scout Master.
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast. This is Clark Green. Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Anne Olson wrote in.
She said this:
Hi, Clark,
Just a quick note as a Minnesotan to let you know the correct pronounci-. the correct
pronounci- the correct pronunciation of Ellie or E-L-Y, home of the Northern
Tier Base, is a long E sound,
So it's L-E, not Eli. like you said before,
We just returned from many point scout camp up that way, but not as quite as far
north as Ellie.
Well, thanks, Anne.
You know we're all flatlanders down here and we don't know how to say things right.
You know, you, betcha.
Thanks once again and thanks for listening and being in touch.
Jamie Humphries wrote in to say I thought I'd say hey. after a full summer we took
our troop to Camp Alexander near Pikes Peak and we had a fantastic time.
Other than a Black Bear adventure and chipmunks taking liberties with our tents, it was
a great first year as Scoutmaster.
Thanks for all the wisdom I've gleaned from the podcast and blog.
It made my first year pretty successful.
Well, thank you, Jamie.
Glad to hear it.
You know if you've been following the blog. recently we had a post about scout leaders
from the scout's perspective
And it was written by a scout who's 17 years old and a blogger.
His first name is Enoch,
And Enoch did an excellent job in writing a post for ScoutmasterCGcom
And Dean replied to it.
He said outstanding reminders and good advice, particularly in the need to see things
from the boy's point of view. how important and yet sometimes how challenging it is
to do that.
Well, that's one of those things we always keep in front of us,
And thank you for your comment, Dean,
And thanks for being in touch.
You can be in touch too.
You're going to find out more about how to do that towards the end of the podcast,
In this podcast in Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less. I want to
share a resource that I found online with you and email question that I
received earlier this year.
I don't think we've put it on the podcast yet, but it concerns spending
time with your son as an adult leader in scouting,
And that's going to about do it for us this time around.
So let's get started, shall we? in seven minutes or less.
One of the scouting resources I follow online very closely is the United States
Scouting Service Project
And in particular, I follow the columns written by Andy under the title Ask Andy.
Andy's been doing this for years and years and some one of these days,
some one of these days, I'm going to get Andy on a podcast.
We've been talking back and forth for quite a while and trying to get the
schedules together and trying to get him to sit down and record an interview with me,
But he had a feature recently about how a scout troop works.
The vast majority of questions and difficulties that we run into as scout
leaders are people who misapprehend exactly what we're trying to
accomplish, because the way a scout troop works is pretty unique in the
world of youth serving organizations.
Back in June, Andy posted a writing by Hal Dommie.
If you listen in and how- and I didn't get your name right- make sure you
get in touch with me and I just want to review it with you and there'll be a link
to this writing on the post that contains this podcast at scoutmastercgcom.
But Hal has very succinctly and very completely described exactly what happens in a scout troop
and this might be a good thing for you to take a look at and either share as it's written or
maybe adapt to share with the new parents and new leaders who are going to be part of your troop.
Hal starts by saying: you know a boy scout troop is a microcosm of democracy and action.
Its key leaders are elected by their peers and then provide direction through the troops
essential operating units, its patrols.
Baden Powell said this: the patrol method is not a way of running a scout troop.
It is the only way of running a scout troop. Without the patrol method, there's no scouting.
When, with the scout masters guidance, scouts form themselves in patrols,
plan the troops annual, monthly and individual meeting programs and bring these for to life.
For this to happen, the troop relies on scouts serving in key positions of responsibility to
make up the primary operational program decision making body of the troop, the patrol leaders
council. Now who's the scout master? The scout master is appointed by the executive officer
of the troops chartered organization with the agreement of the troop committee chair.
The scout master is responsible, in this order, for, one, training and guiding youth leaders in
the operation of their patrols and their troop and two, managing training and supporting the
troops assistant scout masters in their roles. So how do we explain patrols and the patrol
method? The patrol is the fundamental unit of the scout program. The troop is the umbrella
under which the patrols operate. A patrol is a grouping of approximately six,
but really never more than eight, scouts who work together. Each patrol elects its own patrol leader,
who then chooses his assistant patrol leader. Within the larger community of the troop,
the patrol is the scouts family circle. The patrol helps its members develop a sense of pride
and identity and encourages an increasing level of responsibility. The object of the patrol method,
Baden Powell said, is to give responsibility to the scout, and the scout master's handbook
tells us: never do for a boy what he can do for himself. Besides the patrol leader,
other positions in the patrol are the assistant patrol leader, the scribe, the quarter master,
grub master, cheer master. Depending on the situation, patrols may have other types of
duty positions, such as a fire tender and a cook. The patrol leader leads the selection
for those positions. The troops- patrols- do everything together. They meet together, plan
outings together, camp and hike together, learn skills together and come to troop meetings
together. The patrol members are inseparable and each is responsible for and accountable to
all other members of his patrol. Now, beyond patrol leaders, who are the key youth leaders
in a scout troop, The troop, with the guidance of the scout master, is run by these youth leaders
who plan the program, conduct troop meetings and they provide leadership for their peers.
In addition to patrol leaders who compromise the patrol leaders council,
the two most senior youth leaders are the senior patrol leader and the assistant senior patrol
leader. Now the senior patrol leader is the troops go to guide. He leads troop meetings
and the patrol leaders council and, in consultation with the scout master, he appoints
other youth leaders and assigns specific responsibilities as needed. The assistant
senior patrol leader is selected by the senior patrol leader to assist him and the
assistant senior patrol leader fills in for the senior patrol leader in his absence and
is also responsible for training and giving direction to the troops quartermaster scribe
or the arrow troop representative and all those other positions of responsibility.
Some troops use the position of responsibility called a troop guide and that scout
provides guidance for the patrol leader of the new scout patrol.
So now that we understand the overall structure and the positions, we will remember that the
patrol leaders council, not the adult leaders, not the troop committee, is responsible for
planning and conducting all troop activities. The patrol leaders councils comprised of the
key decision makers: the senior patrol leader, the assistant senior patrol leader
and all patrol leaders. Now the troops scribe may be requested to attend a patrol
leaders council meeting, but typically the scout master and assistant scout masters
do not attend patrol leaders council meetings. At the patrol leaders council monthly meetings,
these key youth leaders plan, organize and assign activity responsibilities
for the weekly troop meetings and the coming month. The patrol leaders council also plans
the troops annual calendar of activities. The scout master guides and mentors but
does not lead or control patrol leaders council meetings and program planning,
and then he informs the troop committee of the patrol leaders council plans and decisions.
The troop committee may offer a suggestion to the patrol leaders council through the scout master,
but neither the scout master nor the committee votes on or approves or vetoes or otherwise
disapproves what the patrol leaders council has decided, except in the event of a potential
safety or youth protection violation. House included a model patrol leaders council
monthly meeting agenda about follow-up and follow-through from those meetings
and he also has some information about the annual planning conference. He does talk about
the troop committee, so let's take a look at that. The troop committee supports the troop program
by making sure that a high quality adult leadership is identified, recruited and trained.
by advising the scout master on policies of the BSA and the chartered organization is
necessary. by making sure that the troop has a place to meet and it's adequate and safe.
by taking responsibility for finances, adequate funds and disbursements in line with a formal
budget plan. by obtaining and maintaining troop property like camping gear and things like that.
by assuring that the troop has an outdoor program and including scout summer camp and
supporting it with adequate leadership. by maintaining scout advancement records and
serving on ransom rank advancement boards of review. by encouraging regular courts of honor.
by supporting the scout master and working with boys individually and resolving problems
that may affect the overall troop program. by helping the troop to carry out the annual
friends of scouting fundraising campaign by keeping the adult leader positions needed to
support the troop field For essential utility. the troop committee needs to provide the troop
with these positions: a troop committee chairman, membership chair, advancement chair, finance
chair and an outdoor support chairman. and in this writing, Hal goes on to describe weekly troop
meetings and their different elements and the purposes behind them and, as I said before, the
annual planning process, and then also talks about supporting all this with the monthly
patrol leaders council meeting. really good, succinct look at the way that a troop operates.
it'd be a great introduction, like I said, for new leaders and for parents. I wanted to make you
aware of it and thanks to the folks at the United States scouting service project and
Andy for making us aware of this writing by- uh, by Hal Dommie. there's a link at scoutmastercgcom
at the post that contains podcast 135. write me a letter, send it by name
email. that is folks. and here's an answer to one of your emails.
thanks so much for your podcast. been a regular listener for some time and I've learned a great
deal about scouting. I'm now a scout master and, as I've learned about the patrol method and how
patrols should cook and camp together, I was really kind of disappointed about losing time with my
son. we both prefer to share a tent together and last week I had a father on a potential new scout
visit our troop and he told me that one of his motivations was to spend more time with his son.
he had been meaning to take him camping and such, but it just hadn't happened.
I'm interested in your thoughts on how to reconcile what appeared to be
two conflicting goals of spending time with our sons and working the patrol method.
well, I'll tell you something. the answer to this is going to sound awfully discouraging at first,
but don't despair, because it gets a lot better. scouting is not about creating father, son or
mother son time in the way that you've defined it. it's far from it. you're right, these are
two conflicting things. the process of scouting happens when boys are working together and
adults are only marginally involved in most of their activities. that's that's the patrol method: no
sharing tents with dad, no cooking with dad. that's a pretty bright line. in my way of looking at this,
there's no reconciling the patrol method with the goal of a father and son or a mother and son
spending all kinds of time together during scouting events. they're at opposite ends of the spectrum.
scouting was not conceived with the idea that parents would have direct involvement in the
process, much less use it as a time to spend with their boys. now that I've totally disappointed you,
let me rebuild this. what you're going to find is, in spite of this- and I'm just going to stick
with talking about fathers and sons, since that's the way the question was framed-
fathers and sons get an awful lot out of sharing scouting.
now, as much as you love your son and you really cherish the time you're able to spend together,
scouting is going to help you go closer and provide you for with some just incredible
shared experiences. in the years that I've been involved- the 30 years that I've been involved
in scouting- I've never known a father to regret spending time with his boy and scouts.
I've known some who wish they had spent a great deal more time.
while you and your son won't be sharing tats or meals or actually spending a great deal of time in
each other's company during a scout meeting or an outing, you're going to have plenty to discuss
outside of scouting activities and you can't discount this at all. this is the magical part
of it: the father and son relationship is going to be strained at one point within the next
several years. it's a typical thing. it's a healthy thing. boys pass through adolescence
and it's an important, healthy process for them to be a little bit at odds with their parents
and make their own way in the world. I mean, they have to differentiate themselves from
their parents, don't they? it can be a bit painful and a bit distressing, but if you have scouting
improv in common, even when communications are strained, that few minutes in the car
to or from a scout meeting is an incredible opportunity and an incredible gift.
when a boy joins a scout troop and his dad becomes an adult leader at the same time,
you know the first couple camp outs and maybe meetings and things like that. they're going to
tend to stay in their father's orbit for a little while. they're going to try and stay kind of close
by. but they soon start making their own way with their fellow scouts and they stop looking for
dad every few minutes. you know they stop saying, oh, is he still over there? is he watching me? will I be
okay? is he going to take care of me? but soon they're looking for him less and less and less
until they become fully confident and comfortable on their own, and this is an incredibly important
thing for a boy to accomplish. there's something else that happens- this aspect of sharing this
with other fathers. you'll sit around a lot of campfires and learn a lot from other dads,
and a lot of what you're going to learn is that they're experiencing the same challenges and
triumphs that you are. you'll be able to give each other some perspective and solace when times are
tough, and that's just an immense consolation when you're taking refuge in the company of the
other fathers. your son is taking refuge in the company of other sons. you know my best friends
and confidence have been my fellow scout leaders. when the time finally comes and your son's ready
to make his own way in the world, you'll send him off, having seen him progress through the challenges
of scouting. he'll have some confidence and independence and skills and he'll have what's
needed to take things on that a lot of other people won't have. it's also going to make the
transition easier for you and, in your case, easier for your wife, because you have progressively
learned to let go a little bit at a time through this scouting career in a very conscious way.
decades later, you and your son are still going to have those scouting years that you
spent together. you're going to share an understanding. you're going to have a common
language and a comradeship that really endures. there's no way to explain- i got to tell you
there is no way to explain- how fast all this is going to happen. today he's leaving the fifth grade.
tomorrow he's graduating from college. next week he's presenting you with a grandchild.
it is going to blow your mind how fast this all goes.
so, listen, i'm going to encourage you to rethink things. you need to trust this program and the
scouting process. it really does work. it really does. it will give your son tremendous advantages
and it's also going to give you a lot of advantages. in the end, you're going to give up one way of
spending time with your son for another, and that one, in my experience, is just an immensely rich
and highly treasured thing to be able to spend time with your child in in in the scouting program.
so, listen, i hope that helps and i hope it makes the way clear for you and your son to actually
really spend spend time together while you're both involved in scouting.
hey, thanks for listening to this edition of the scout master podcast. here's how you keep in touch.
first go to scoutmastercgcom. that's where the blog is and you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email. you can subscribe to the scout master podcast on itunes. if you have
the chance, leave a comment or review a rating. that always helps us out. let's just know how we're
doing. you can also access the podcast on your mobile device through stitcher smart radio
and get details about how to do that. at stitchercom, you can call and record a shout out for the
scout master podcast. go to scoutmastercgcom, look for the shout out link and it'll give you
instructions on exactly how to do that and your shout out will be featured in the next scout master
podcast. you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of social media
outlets. that's right. you can follow us at scoutmaster blog on facebook, tweet scoutmastercg on
twitter and, for admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg circle, search for scoutmastercg
on google plus. remember, you can always email me, clark green, with your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet. did you know? the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America? where you ought to.
you also need to know that they're not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America. it's
just me. i've got a microphone and i'm talking into it, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and
maybe have a little bit of fun along the way. finally, we want to hear from our founder, Sir
Robert Baden Powell. sir robert, good luck to you and group camping why? thank you, sir, until next time
you.